[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in Dan orlovski ESPN NFL
analyst and former NFL quarterback you
can see him on NFL live Monday through
Friday at 4 Easter so now it's personal
with the Cowboys and the 49ers after
that how do you explain
that it's it's a tough one to try to
wrap your head around you know if it
just as knowing the type of competitor
that Micah Parsons is at least from the
out side and the way that that game was
played and looked the way that the last
three times those teams have played and
looked so um I'm a huge fan of Micah I
think that you know when you know when
you have kind of your own platform
you've got to be responsible for the
things that you say and he's going to
have to know that people are going to
dissect this opinion that he had so I
think Micah when he even after the game
d he was like they're not that much
better than us Mah they should have hung
50 plus on you guys you know that there
we can sit here and say that the 49ers
are absolutely in a class higher than
the Dallas Cowboys so um you know
hopefully the the rest of his team kind
of takes it personal if and when the
next time these two meet how do we not
overreact to that outcome whether it's
what the Cowboys lack or you know what
the strengths are of the
Niners uh I don't think we have to
overreact Dan I think we could talk
about San Francisco and say this they
are absolutely who they have been for
the past four or five years but better
and I think the one reason is and I said
this on NFL live I think maybe yesterday
or Friday or whatever I really believe
that Brock perie has unlocked a
different level in Kyle Shanahan Kyle
Shanahan has always been a phenomenal
offensive mind he's been one of the best
in the NFL but in many ways like ky's
offense certainly in San Francisco was
very horizontal and it was awesome and
Jimmy G was awesome in it not awesome
Jimmy G was really good in it Brock P's
kind of ability to still stretch the
ball
downfield accurately and at the right
times has allowed Kyle to stretch it out
horizontally and vertically at the same
time and that really wasn't the case
that often you know I if you go back in
the third quarter and and this is why
San Francisco in my eyes is different
and this is why it's a different Kyle
it's third and three they're up 2110
with like8 minutes third and three and
he throws the shake route or Corner
route to Brandon auk it's perfect versus
Man coverage holding brings him back it
goes to third and 13 to Third and 14 now
usually Kyle would throw some form of
like a screen there a perimeter screen
and they'll go get it this y on Sunday
night he throws another dropback big in
route to Debo Samuel and pery Lofts it
over the backers perfectly in stride
that that I see that as a different
offense because of Brock pie so we could
say say that about San Francisco in
regards to Dallas
um Dallas is a really good football team
it's we can't say that they're not
really good but we it it is also
accurate for us to say that we thought
that they would be a upgrade this year
than they were last year and after
Sunday night we can't say that we can't
say that they're a legitimate Super Bowl
Contender when they just got the floor
wiped by San Francisco in the way that
they're offense looked and the way that
their stagnant play calling was and the
way that Dak played and the minimization
of their defense we can't say that so I
don't think it's an overreaction
no if uh I find it interesting the swing
of emotions or opinions on Brock pting
that it was well he's surrounded by all
this talent to now he's the next Joe
Montana or Tom Brady with uh you know
similar skill set you know Rex Ryan
talked about that on get up where he's
like oh my God you know I see Tom Brady
or Charlie Weiss oh I I see Joe Montana
here um he's not he's not Tom Brady from
the physical attributes I mean he would
be more like Montana you know slight of
build has a little bit more athleticism
not necessarily a great arm but how did
everybody miss on that every team passed
on him seven times if he has all of
these innate abilities you know but we
missed it
I mean why how San Francisco missed on
him for six rounds too so yeah you know
it's funny Dan so I called his game
against Notre Dame I it was his bowl
game and I think it might have been his
sophomore or Junior year I I don't
exactly remember the year and you you
saw he was like a really good college
quarterback um but you you didn't walk
away going that dude's gonna be awesome
in the NFL and Anthony Beck actually
texted me during the draft process of
last year Anthony Beck longtime NFL
tight end and he said tell me what
everyone's missing or how everyone's
missing on Brock pie like what what are
they what are they not seeing and I
would just responded back like I think
he's a really good college football
player I don't know you know if if I see
awesome NFL player um why did everyone
Miss I think one the most important
traits that a quarterback can have for
highlevel consistent success
he has and they're the ones you can't
measure what do you do in moments of
panic with the football how quickly do
you understand the information and then
apply the information on a play bypl
bypl by play bypl basis what decision do
you make at the at what moment you know
and and um you know how do you kind of
see the whole field without not being
obsessed with seeing just a certain
aspect or person or defense I I listen
Dan there's no quarterback in the NFL
that plays at a really high level
without really good players and coaching
around them we just don't see that and
it's no there's no quarterback in the
NFL that has bad players or coaches
around them that plays at a high level
maybe other than like Lamar for
stretches so it always takes this um
Brock prie is a really good player that
is playing at an incredibly high level I
I think it's R not ridiculous I think
it's unfair for us to put him in a Josh
Allen Patrick Mahomes uh Justin Herbert
Joe burough Lamar conversation but he
absolutely has earned the right to be in
that top 10 borderline conversation um
and he's he's playing he's playing
exactly how Kyle needs him to play Dan
orlovski of the Mother Ship you can see
him NFL live Monday through Friday at 4
Eastern you can also see him on First
Take and Get Up and some of the other
properties there at the mother ship the
Justin Jefferson injury
what's the Fallout going to
be the Vikings have one Focus right now
easy for me to say I'm not in the locker
room how do we keep Justin
Jefferson that that's I think their
number one thing they're not a playoff
football I didn't think they play a
football team with Justin I don't think
they're obviously going to be one
without Justin and so now because of the
injury because of the the way the team's
playing and obviously because of where
Kirk sits contract wise there's a lot of
question marks and I think
organizationally they have to have the
very hard question of like how do we
keep Justin Jefferson what's the what's
the way and I think the easy thing is
like well money everyone's gonna pay
want to pay Justin Jefferson it it's not
going to be just the money thing Justin
I would imagine wants to play with a
really good quarterback at a very high
level who he thinks he's going to be
there for a longterm period of time
whether he determines that Kurt cousin
or not I don't know Devonte Adams
sounded a little frustrated last night
he had one target first half he had four
targets the entire game and after the
game and then I heard some of his
comments and I'm thinking if I'm the
Raiders do I at least explore trading
him maybe reuniting him with Derek Carr
like where where are the Raiders go I
don't think Jimmy G is the quarterback
next year or Josh McDaniels is the coach
at with the Raiders so what like where
are you going with that team that roster
and a guy who is 30 years of age used to
being you know singled out getting a lot
of targets and now you get one in the
first half yeah and it's weird because I
just watched Cincinnati without T
Higgins throw the ball 19 times to Jamar
Chase on Sunday you know so that's why
overall Dan I I never like when people
are like well you know it's hard to get
your guy the ball when they're double
teaming them I no I've I've thrown the
ball to Kelvin Johnson 15 times in a
game when he was getting double team so
you throw the ball to those guys you
know um you know that's I think on the
treetop you go absolutely because I
don't think that the Raiders are our
real player right now but it's easy to
say that when you're not Josh you're not
Dave Ziggler they're general manager and
so if those guys have security then it's
probably a worthy conversation because
then maybe you provide yourself assets
to go get a quarterback in the next
we know that they tried to go get CJ
strad this past year but if those guys
are still in limbo I don't think you can
move him because he's by far yeah your
best offensive player yeah how does
Caleb Williams not become the
next the next what superstar
yeah um I think that there's probably
one gripe I have about Caleb's game I
think Caleb is unbelievable and he's at
worst going to be the number two pick in
the NFL draft at worst he does not play
a ton in structure he does not play a
ton on time now part of that is his
style part of that is because he's the
best player on the field usually every
game part of that is because he creates
a ton of big plays and it's a little bit
of Patrick Mahomes in them right there
there is a little bit of that that that
mindset um we have seen those guys that
are outrageously talented have to do
that the NFL for periods of time we've
seen it with Patrick Mahomes we've seen
it with Josh Allen we've seen it with
Lamar can Caleb get there I would
imagine so he's incredibly talented I
just haven't seen it at the the college
level probably because it hasn't been
asked and or demanded of him but that
would be the only reason why other than
like injury or something God forbid but
he's a superstar him and Drake May it's
G to be a fascinating debate who's gonna
go
one oh so you think there's still once
the scouts get a hold of these guys the
teams get a hold of these guys that you
think there's a chance Drake may could
be the first quarterback off the board
oh absolutely yeah I I I'm a huge Drake
May fan um okay I'm gonna give you the
number one pick I'm gonna you're the
Bears got the number one pick right now
right now man um I think right now I
still take Kaleb Williams that's without
studying you know these guys in and out
over into the spring right now take
Caleb I've called a couple of Drake May
games uh he I will not be alone in
thinking he is going to be in
conversation for the number one pick I
promise you that he's he's got a lot of
Big Ben in his game Big
Ben yeah big time okay and then big
athletic powerful dude still sloppy
mechanically a little bit um but great
vision great feel uh throws a beautiful
different lever different leveled or
layered football he he's awesome sounds
like you're in love I think he's a
superstar in the NFL I do okay uh the
wall behind you got you with all your
uniforms is that uh all the all the
stops in your career who painted yeah
man yeah man that's also when I yell at
my kids the same face I make
cult you remember um do you remember the
name Chris Meyers he was the longtime
great center for the Texans pro bowler
for a bunch of years
um him and I teammates and he had
actually that painted for me so uh it's
kind of the only thing I have in my
house of my playing day so so if I
walked in it' take me a while to realize
you played in the NFL yeah I don't I
don't I I try I fight with my wife all
the time because my wife wants to put
all stuff up and all that and I am uh
like very against it because we have
four kids three of them are boys I don't
want my boys to feel like this
overwhelming pressure that dad did this
so you have to go do that type of thing
so um yeah well it's kind of weird
though you have that painting in your
bedroom oh this is my office oh it's
your office Oh I thought it was in your
bedroom my bad oh this isn't just a
shrine to me in my bedroom
no it's a lot of footballs back there
there's helmets back there yeah well
that was my wife did that that was the
one thing I let her do because um during
coid we were working from home so much
you know the the background with the
camera shot was there and so she was
like I want to do stuff so footballs
helmets I could show you look we
got that's signed by Calvin I probably
made his
career Calvin Johnson signed a football
to you I just um my agents at CIA just
sent me someone on Twitter was like made
a like a highlight cut of mine and they
were like look at this guy so I just put
it on Twitter and I wrote could have
been a Hall of Fame career um also is
Calvin in the Hall of Fame without this
three minute stretch okay Kobe Bryant
book Pine Valley uh my wife's Marathon
medals so yeah bobblehead then you Dan
bobblehead wow look at that yeah man
yeah and and there's no more stepping
out of the end zone jokes anymore right
you're off the I don't think I don't
think those are going
away you your celebration though on
social media was awesome you're off the
hook not the only guy who stepped
through the uh through the end zone it's
twice in two years Jimmy garoo who's
made like1 million dollar and Gardner
menu who's like the best backup
quarterback maybe like in the last 10
years of football or something I was out
of full so uh I'm in good company I
would go to that party if it's you Jimmy
G and Gardner mshu and you're having a
party of quarterbacks who've stepped out
of the end zone while attempting a pass
I'd go to that social I'd have to be the
least fascinating of the three though
just if you if we think about some of
the things that Jimmy certainly has been
attached to off the field and then mu is
is a is a walking documentary I guess so
uh I would be the least fascinating of
the three great to talk to you again Dan
thank you we appreciate your time thanks
bud that's Dan orlovski NFL live Monday
through Friday at 4 Eastern and a former
NFL quarterback